paul's had a big half as well played a
ton of minutes now another three-pointer
is up
oh chris paul
now paul matched up on the rookie year
15 versus year one
keeping that dribble alive tough step
back and he got it to go
oh man he put him in the spin cycle
chris paul nice in and out dribble pull
up and won
this is chris paul doing chris paul
things
a big shock for the milo galinari paul
with the steal
ball pit three and the thunder with six
quick ones you should never leave the
game
until you see zeroes on the clock
because that's what chris paul said
paul navigating tough fade away shot
over yoke and he got the bounce
that's the maid shot of the previous
possession over yokit a little run here
to end the third kind of what we saw
with them
the thunder right before halftime that's
when harden was sitting
and noel batting that back out chris
paul
flipping it up and in the field goal and
the foul
keenly aware that you had the advantage
chris paul one dribble
jeff green on his side initiates the
contact soft touch
haven't seen much of him in this second
half
again paul working on green oh chris
paul
taking jeff green one on one last two
possessions and drops a couple of
mid-range jumpers on him
eric gordon came in struggling but now
he's knocking in shots
chris paul down the lane oh man
the bucket and the body and an
opportunity for the three-point play
muscala making just his second start of
the season
says he's really found a home here in
oklahoma city ball two-on-one odd man
rush sets it up
and diallo [ __ ] it back
oh you've had a lot of deflections
already reflections you've been able to
cash in right now the thunder
12 points off nine turnovers this is
coming off a turnover
paul's had a big half as well played a
ton of minutes now another three-pointer
is up oh
chris paul what a big shot for chris
paul again
another made three for paul doubtful to
return for the last two minutes and 15
seconds of this game
wow chris paul butter
chris paul come on come on
and it's especially sweet against a
former teammate in austin rivers
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher